pouvait présentement dans ce sous-sol
mission mile end à montréal
je suis dacc thériault coin glee il suit
le co directeur de clinique dentaire
mobile de l'université de mcgill on
donne des soins dentaires gratuites à
des personnes
deva vos déguisements ça fait vingt ans
que ça existe c'est écrit barret docteur
michael wiseman il l'a trouvé quelques
d'enterrer ce qu'ils voulaient faire du
bénévole de traiter des personnes en
perte d'autonomie a donc débuté dans un
hôpital gériatrique un pique nique sur
le sort des étudiants de 3e année c'est
eux qui font le traitement et
d'étudiants de première année travaille
comme assistante nécessaire pour de de
participer dans ce problème pour
terminer le jeu le permettent de voir
une population qui n'a pas accès aux
soins est d'un peu plus de l'humilité
en important des tentes est donc c'est
pour des personnes qui gagnent pas assez
d'argent dame de payer pour des
traitements dentaires ainsi pas couverts
mama
d'avoir un mot de danse est sorti la
langue
quelqu'un qui n'a pas de bon d'avoir des
problèmes psychologiques
peut-être un
des problèmes sociaux luan bon travail
[Musique]
dans leur communauté et 3,4 inique
une date est un peu bas on
une trentaine de personnes
on fait juste le dépistage entre
l'examen en fait juste base mais on
prépare un plan d action qui peut faire
des beaux les patients qui sont réussir
on les réfère à l'université pour
recevoir des traitements un peu plus
complexes dans des extractions des
plantages et c'est nous qui paye pour
tout le traitement dont cliniques sont
toujours pleines
il ya toujours une liste d'attentes donc
il me manque pas dépasser mariale une
messe de la belle ils ont des cliniques
fixe pour des personnes défavorisées
mais on est le seul avec un clinique
mobile
c'est essentiel pour moi ça fait 20 ans
j'espère que ça continue
peut-être grandi un peu plus mais on
verra
[Musique]